They were the stupid years, what they were
doing was incredible,
NAFTA, one of the world's worst trade deals
ever, I know a couple of others
we've been involved in them too.
By erecting tariffs and threatening to tear
up free trade agreements,
President Donald Trump has done more to advance
one of the left's long standing policy goals
than any other modern President.
And he also sounds a lot like some of the
Democratic candidates
that are running to unseat him in the next
election.
Bernie Sanders sill brags about how he opposed
the North American Free Trade Agreement
when it was ratified by Congress in 1994.
In 2011, the Vermont Senator even went after
the Smithsonian Institution
for selling Chinese made toys.
We should not be selling statues of the founding
fathers of this country
and have them made in China.
From the World Trade Organization protests
in Seattle in 1999 to the 2016 campaign trail,
The left has traditionally opposed free trade
on the grounds that it hurts American workers.
I hope in fact, all across the board, we begin
to focus on rebuilding our manufacturing sector
so that we create millions of jobs in products
made in the United States.
But it's Donald Trump who has made at least
some of those dreams come true.
We're asking Bernie Sanders voters to join
our movement.
This creates a conundrum:
the Democrats running for office in 2020 can't
say that they like what Trump is doing
but they're also not really willing to criticize
his trade war.
Your approach to trade with China is very
similar to the President's.
No it is not.
He's talking about how we're getting ripped
of left and right on trade.
And I think you know I can take that paragraph
and just use it in my speeches
since what I'm saying it's one of my big things.
US trade policy has delivered one punch in
the gut after another.
Trump and anti-trade Democrats fail to grasp
that nations don't really trade with one another at all.
Individuals and corporations do,
and sometimes those individuals and corporations
want to buy or sell something to someone in another country.
And trade is the source of our wealth,
since 1950, international trade boosted Americans'
per household income
by about 18 thousand dollars.
And the gains flowed dis-proportionally to
lower income households.
If they can save a nickel by moving a job
to Mexico, they'll do it in a heartbeat.
Elizabeth is absolutely right,
for anybody here that thinks that corporate
America
gives one damn about the average American
worker, you're mistaken.
But American manufacturing jobs peaked at
about 20 million in 1979.
That's 15 years before NAFTA.
Until bottoming out at 11.4 million in 2011.
The reason for that decline isn't shifting
jobs overseas, it's automation.
Manufacturing output has doubled since the
mid 1980s.
America makes more stuff than ever, our factories
just don't require as many workers as they once did.
Even supposedly centrist candidates like Senator
Kamala Harris
have shifted into protectionist mode.
In an interview with Jake Tapper in May,
Harris said she wouldn't have voted for NAFTA
if she'd been in the Senate when it passed.
I believe that we have got to have policy
that better protects American workers and
American industries.
Harris did criticize Trump's use of tariffs,
calling the President's habit of conducting
trade policy,
economic policy, foreign policy by tweet 'irresponsible.'
But that really drives home my point.
Democrats seem happy to criticize Trump's
haphazard handling of the trade war.
But many of the 2020 candidates are at least
tacitly endorsing the same protectionist views.
Even Joe Biden, once a pro trade Democrat,
is now backing away from his record for fear
of upsetting the progressive left.
I would not rejoin the TTP as it was initially
put forward.
The Democrats are essentially arguing
that all we need is a more competent protectionist
in the White House.
I think Trump gets it wrong in terms of implementation.
But there's no way to correctly implement
a policy
that stops individuals from freely exchanging
goods and services
just because they live in different countries.
Thanks to President Donald Trump, Bernie Sanders'
vision
of restricting our ability to peacefully trade
with one another has become policy.
And that's a catastrophe for all Americans.